Where the hell have you been?
Oh no, take your time, Urs.
It's only our entire lives
on the line here.
Ben didn't do it.
What did you do with the Pento?
Have you got it?
How can you be sure he didn't?
Because he ended it Bibi, okay?
That's how.
He wouldn’t do that for me.
I don't know what I was thinking.
I’ve ruined it all.
Ugh, Urs.
Okay, if anyone in this room did it,
we need to say.
I mean it.
No one is going to have to
deal with this alone.
We'll close ranks circling.
It's the only way we can all be protected.
Urs?
She was on her own all night.
Who’s to say she didn't?
Because I didn't.
Because she didn't.
Okay, so both of you get
automatically believed
And I have to provide a bloody alibi?
She didn't have someone else involved.
She's a f*cking psycho.
[Surprised laugh]
I'm not the one who tried to kill someone
so my husband didn't discover my affair.
Would you just stop, okay?
B*tch!
Just stop!
You’re the psycho!
Where were you, Becka?
I need to know where you were that night.
Why was there mud on your shoes?
I got hammered at the pub,
Miss f*cking Marple!
I was worried you would
do something reckless,
so I got pissed.
Taught me well.
Don't talk to her like that.
What are you fighting about?
Um, nothing.
Uh, just politics.
Ever since John Paul died, whenever
I walk into the room, you stop talking.
No, we don't.
What's happened, Grace? Are you okay?
They did a post-mortem on John Paul.
My signature is on this.
Like I agreed to it.
Those dirty bastards.
Shut up.
Oh my God.
You knew about it.
You knew about the post-mortem.
Why did they exhume John Paul's body?
Because they think he was murdered.
And they think it was one of us
who did it.
One of you?
Why would they think that?
Because they think
we all had a reason to kill him.
- And because...
- No!
Just stop lying to her!
Because we may not have killed him.
Jesus, we tried.
What are you talking about?
What does that mean?
We tried.
We wanted John Paul dead, Gracie.
We were doing it for you.
We wanted to save you.
We wanted you and Blánaid to be free.
[Heavy breaths]